so I started to work on a
fun chip I was like okay what's it going
to take to make a chip
and my first Notions were all completely
wrong about why about like how you could
improve on gpus uh and I will take this
this is from uh Jim Keller on your
podcast uh and this is one of my
absolute favorite
descriptions of computation
so there's three kinds of computation
paradigms that are common in the world
today
other CPUs and CPUs can do everything
CPUs can do add and multiply they can do
load and store and they can do compare
and branch and when I say they can do
these things they can do them all fast
right so compare and Branch are unique
to CPUs and what I mean by they can do
them fast is they can do things like
Branch prediction and speculative
execution and they spend tons of
transistors on these like super deep
reorder buffers in order to make these
things fast
then you have a simpler computation
model gpus gpus can't really do compare
and Branch I mean they can but it's
horrendously slow
but gpus can do arbitrary load in store
right gpus can do things like X
dereference Y so they can fetch from
arbitrary pieces of memory they can
fetch from memory that is defined by the
contents of the data
um the third model of computation dsps
and dsps are just add and multiply
right like they can do load in stores
but only static load in stores only
loads and stores that are known before
the program runs and you look at neural
networks today and 95 of neural networks
are all the DSP paradigm
they are just statically scheduled ads
and multiplies
so tinyguard really took this idea and
and I'm still working on it to extend
this as far as possible
um every stage of the stack has turned
completeness right python has turned
completeness and then we take python we
go into C plus plus which is starting to
complete and maybe C plus calls into
some Cuda kernels which are turn
complete the Cuda kernels go through lvm
which is turning complete into PTX which
is turn completely into SAS which is
turn complete on a turn complete
processor I want to get turn
completeness out of the stack entirely
because once you get rid of torrent
completeness you can reason about things
Rice's theorem and the halting problem
do not apply to Admiral machines
okay what's the power and the value of
getting torn completeness out of out of
are we talking about the hardware or the
software every layer of a stack every
layer every layer of the stack removing
turn completeness allows you to reason
about things right so the reason you
need to do Branch prediction in a CPU
and the reason it's prediction and the
branch predictors are I think they're
like 99 on CPUs why do they get one
percent of them wrong well they get one
percent wrong because you can't know
right that's the halting problem it's
equivalent to the halting problem to say
whether a branch is going to be taken or
not
um I can show that but
the
Admiral machine the neural network runs
the identical compute every time the
only thing that changes is the data
so when you realize this you think about
okay how can we build a computer and how
can we build a stack that takes maximal
advantage of this idea
uh so what makes tiny grad different
from other neural network libraries is
it does not have a primitive operator
even for matrix multiplication and this
is every single one they even have
primitive operators things like
convolutions so no matte mole no mammal
well here's what a map is so I'll use my
hands to talk here so if you think about
a cube and I put my two matrices that
I'm multiplying on two faces of the cube
right you can think about the Matrix
multiply as okay the N cubed I'm going
to multiply for each one in the cubed
and then I'm going to do a sum which is
a reduce up to here to the third face of
the cube and that's your multiplied
Matrix
so what a matrix multiply is is a bunch
of shape operations right a bunch of
permute three shapes and expands on the
two matrices
a multiply n cubed a reduce n cubed
which gives you an N squared Matrix
okay so what what is the minimum number
of operations that can accomplish that
if you don't have uh map Mall as a
primitive so tiny grad has about 20. um
and you can compare tiny grad's uh opsat
or IR to things like xla or Prim torch
so xla and Prim torch are ideas we're
like okay torch has like 2 000 different
kernels
um
Pi torch 2.0 introduced Prim torch which
has only 250.
tiny grad has order of magnitude 25.
it's it's 10x less than xli or Prim
torch
and you can think about it as kind of
like Risk versus Sisk right these other
things are cisc like systems uh
tendergrad is risk
and risk one risk architecture is going
to change everything 1995 hackers
wait really that's an actual thing
Angelina Jolie delivers the line risk
architecture is going to change
everything in 1995. and here we are with
arm and the phones
an arm everywhere wow I love it when
movies actually have real things in them
right